a horrific horrific weekend will tell
you everything you need to know about
what happened in Charlottesville
Virginia and violence breaking out all
over the country I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show okay so we have
just an enormous amount to get you today
I want to explain to you the roots of
what happened in Charlottesville
Virginia I want to explain to you the
violence of an T if I want to explain to
the violence of the alt-right
and what the alt-right is and why people
on the right arm is perceiving what the
alt-right is we're gonna go through all
of that so it's gonna be a very
difficult show I mean I don't want to
you know pitch this badly but but the
fact is that we're gonna go through a
lot of very difficult and nasty material
today because unfortunately what we saw
in Charlottesville Virginia over the
weekend is the apotheosis of the
nastiness that's been building in our
country for the last several years and
it came to a head on Saturday in
Charlottesville so we'll talk about all
of that but before we get to that I
first want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at ring so rings mission
is to make a neighborhood safer today
over a million people are using the
amazing ring video doorbell device to
protect their homes the way that it
begins is that if somebody tries to
knock on your door and then knows that
you're not home they might break into
your house ring gives you this doorbell
where they they hit the doorbell and you
can pick up the doorbell from anywhere
you are it can be across the country and
you know that your front door is ringing
there's a camera on it so you can tell
who's at your front door whether to let
them in or not it cuts down on home
burglaries by a tremendous percentage
and right now they have security
programs for the rest of your home the
ring floodlight cam is one just like
rings amazing doorbell floodlight
cameras and motion activated camera and
floodlight that connects right to your
phone with HD video and two-way audio
that lets you know the moment anyone
steps on your property you can see and
speak to visitors and even set off an
alarm right from your phone when
something goes bump in the night you're
going to know about it with ring
floodlight cam it's the ultimate in home
security program with ring you're always
at home save up to one hundred and fifty
dollars off a ring of security kit when
you go to ring calm slash Bend that's
ring comm slash Ben again you get one
hundred fifty dollars off that ring of
security kid it's such a good products
that I've even bought extra products for
family members ring of security kick go
get it same of one hundred and fifty
bucks
ring calm / Ben ring.com / man that also
no lets them know that we sent you okay
so I first want to go through what
exactly happened in Charlottesville and
then press
and Trump's response who the various
players are by the end of today's show
you're gonna need to know you're gonna
know everything that you need to know
about the current status of relations
between the social justice warrior your
left and the alt-right you're going to
know everything you need to know about
the Trump administration and their
relationship with the alt-right you
didn't know what the alt-right is by the
end of today's show so today's a very
information driven show and and also I
have to say that there are just so many
garbage people who refuse to acknowledge
evil on any side of the left refusing to
acknowledge the evil Amenti feel you
have the right many on the right
refusing to acknowledge the evils of the
alt-right or trying to blame the evils
of the alt-right on the sjw's it is
possible to hold two thoughts in your
mind at the same time the social justice
warrior left the antifa race politics
intersectionality left is vile and
antiva is getting violent and all this
has been true for months and the
alt-right is a vile disgusting repulsive
utterly morally inconceivable movement
the alt-right is a horrible movement and
just because you think you're all right
doesn't actually mean you're all right
we're going to explain to you what the
roots of the alt-right are where it came
from how it was mainstream and who
mainstreamed it and we're gonna talk
about President Trump's response to all
this so let's just jump right in let's
start with what actually happened so
here's some of the video on Saturday
there was something called unite the
right unite the right was an event
organized by people like Richard Spencer
a bunch of white supremacists decide
that they are going to white separates
this white nationalist decide they're
going to put together this March in
Charlottesville Virginia and they get I
guess about a thousand people to show up
on Friday night they have a torchlight
parade holding tiki torches and it's a
bunch of nerdy losers who have never
been laid in their lives showing up to
to talk about how black people are awful
and they think this makes them cool they
did that on Friday night and then in
Charlottesville the next day they were
doing a March and things take a turn for
the worse that Santee fush owes up and
some of the protesters I'm sure are
people who are not antiva they just want
to protest the white supremacy the white
supremacism that they're seeing on
display and some of the people
definitely rnt for the violent people
are antiva it's sort of like what
happened at Berkeley when Miley
innopolis spoke there he had the some
leftist protesters who showed up and
then an Tifa came in and decided to make
the whole thing violence we've seen this
sort of thing happen all over the
country so that's nothing new okay we
saw that happen at Berkeley and we've
had on people on the show who were
victims of that violence in Berkeley
we've seen it happen in Sacramento
California we saw it happen in Seattle
again over the weekends we're going to
show you some of this footage so here is
so here is a little bit of the video of
an Tifa getting violence in
Charlottesville on Saturday so you can
see that it's hard to tell which
protesters are which some of the some of
the white supremacists carrying
confederate flags i guess some of them
had Nazi flags just disgusting people
walking down the street and some media
members and then you're gonna see in
just a second
some auntie four people and we'll fire
left of your screen jump into action and
now everybody's counting on each other
people swinging flags at each other a
girl getting hit and her her going after
a die
[Applause]
so it turns into a melee first thing
that you do have to ask is where the
hell out of the police where the hell
are the police I mean this is a
legitimate question to be asking at this
point you know we've seen these sorts of
violence incidents break out again they
did in Seattle over the weekend school
show you some tape of that they've been
breaking out all over the country and
the police seem to either be overwhelmed
or to have stands down orders I don't
know where the governor of Virginia is
knowing this is going on but this is a
situation where the National Guard
should be there listen the alt-right is
disgusting awful okay I've been spending
a year I was number one target of the
alt-right last year in the journalistic
community I received over 8,000 nasty
anti-semitic racist tweets directed at
me in the middle of last year's election
cycle specifically because I was anti
all right and they still have a right to
speak and they still have a right to
March and they should be protected by
the police so I don't know where the
police aren't any of this about what's
funny is that you can see auntie for
jumping into action and getting violent
the the left has tried to suggest that
an Tifa was not involved in the violence
in any way now and Tifa being involved
in the violence does not justify either
the perspective or the violence you're
gonna see from the all right okay none
of that justifies any of this but it
would be remiss factually speaking to
pretend that aunt Eva was not involved
in this aunty Fay is a communist group
and Tifa is basically a bunch of Reds
fighting a bunch of brown shirts so
we're now having a replay of the vitamin
Republic Reds versus brown shirts on
American streets one of the things that
was amazing is that a reporter for The
New York Times acknowledged as much a
reporter from the New York Times Cheryl
gates Tolbert she tweeted out the hard
right seems as hateful the hard left
seemed as hate filled as alt right I saw
Club wielding an Tifa beating white
nationalists being led out of the park
okay and a bunch of people on the left
and hit her and they said well they
weren't hate-filled they weren't
hate-filled and she retracted and she
said oh they weren't hateful they were
just violent hey no they can be
hate-filled too and that is in York
Times reporter saying all okay so you
can see some of the violence it looks
like it was launched by an sefa but some
of the violence obviously was coming
from the white supremacist to here's
some of the white supremacist getting
violence I guess this is another point
during this during this March
you see the white supremacist guy
charging into the crowd people hitting
each other you can tell the white
supremacist because they're tearing this
up this shield this white supremacy
field to white black they're beating the
hell out of each other
provoke some Confederate flags and all
the rest of us
and now you can see okay so that's
enough about one we can also see that
some of the that some of the people who
were who were arrested in
Charlottesville were members left so
again I'm trying to point out that the
violence at the beginning was on both
sides then we'll get to the actual
murder okay so the violence was on both
sides in this particular instance now
that's not to say that people who are
anti white supremacy are the same
morally as people who are white
supremacist they're not and it's also
not to say that Reds are the same as
everybody who's in the crowd because
that's not true either but it is fair to
say that violence on all sides is not
appropriate in civilized society here is
clip 26 there is it that one of the guys
arrested in Charlottesville was it was a
counter protester who punched a female
reporter
recording hey MA okay so you can't
really see much there but the woman
who's holding the cameras reporter and
she socked in the head by one of the
auntie presumably counter-protesters
this is not rare okay so to pretend that
the left is not violence in these
situations is just it's just dishonest
okay so you can see that the
Charlottesville organizer right people
were celebrating this but the organizer
of this Charlottesville March he was
doing a press conference on Saturday
after all of this and he was punched in
the face and chased off the grounds
where the cops for all of this
[Applause]
there he is business twerp getting
chased off the grounds and then you'll
see someone come in and clocking
[Applause]
in case they chase him away again is any
of that justified in a civilized society
no it really is not this guy's a piece
of crap that doesn't mean he gets a
bunch pieces of crap in the United
States
right there he goes down ok so again the
violence so I so again the violence was
happening from both the left and the
right here in by the way it's happening
across the country from the left okay so
in Richmond there was a photojournalist
who is he was covering another one of
these rallies and the photojournalist
was hit by a member of an Tifa here at
Jesus clip 27 the guy gets hit right so
again another one of these hands Haifa
protestors who decides to hit a reporter
in in Seattle yesterday there was
another one of these rallies this time
it was not a white supremacist versus
red rally this was apparently just a pro
Trump group that has openly disavowed
any sort of white supremacism and the
antiva protesters show up and start
beating the crap out of people
the police are trying to protect the the
people who are marching you can see that
you can see they're starting to be
they're starting to be hit by the
left-wing protesters the police are
being hit by the left-wing protesters
okay so this sort of stuff has been
happening all over the country the left
has been ignoring it because they prefer
to focus in on the narrative about right
wing violence now to pretend that right
wing violence doesn't exist is stupid
okay it does okay when I say right wing
I mean alt right because there is a
difference between constitutional
conservatism is all explained and the
alt-right alt-right is anti sjw but they
are not conservative in any market way
in any real way they opposed the
Declaration of Independence they opposed
the Constitution of the United States
they're not in favor of individual
liberty they are not in favor of
equality before God they're not in favor
of any of those things we'll explain
what the alt right is in just a second
so to call it right-wing violence is
even they're a bit of a misnomer but of
course the the most important and
horrifying thing that happened on
Saturday was the tape we've not yet
shown and this is a natural type of
murder taking place this is a 20 year
old piece of crap alt writer from Ohio
who takes his car and rams it into a
bunch of the protesters against the
alt-right in Charlottesville here's the
actual tape of it
there comes the car you see him he
actually accelerates into the crowd one
dead 19 injured and then people crowd
around behind the car and the guy
reverses and comes back at 40 miles an
hour down the street and one dead is a
32 year old woman who's there to protest
against these alt-right pieces of human
debris just awful awful awful awful in
every way just awful in every way so in
a second I'm gonna explain to you what
exactly the alt-right is where it came
from why it's important and why it is
that everyone a good conscience has an
obligation to call out the alt-right for
what it is how it got prominent because
I think the difference here what we're
seeing now and this is the problem there
have been white supremacists my entire
life okay there's a guy named buford
furrow who when i was probably 11 years
let's see was 97 i think so maybe I was
Lily or maybe I was it maybe it was a 95
or so Buford furrow was a white
supremacist who came in to Los Angeles
he scoped out the Simon Wiesenthal
Center I went to high school next to the
Simon Wiesenthal Center he scoped it out
because he wanted to shoot a bunch of
Jews when he saw there was security he
left he went over to the JCC in the West
Valley and he proceeded to shoot a bunch
of people the JCC in the West Valley
white supremacist violence has been a
thing in the United States for a long
time since 2001 there have been an
enormous number of white supremacist
attacks on people in the past few months
there have been an enormous number of
white supremacist attacks on people to
pretend that these don't exist is to
ignore reality it's not to suggest that
they're the only people committing
violence but who cares that's not the
point the point is that there are a
group of white supremacist who do commit
violence and they were always a fringe
group but now you are seeing white
supremacist people who hold that
ideology marching openly in the streets
celebrating and something has changed
and we're going to talk about what has
changed in just a second but first I
want to talk to you about an advertiser
and thank them for their sponsorship the
5-4 club so 5-4 club is a fantastic
fantastic service what they do is they
ensure that you are well dressed even if
you don't know how to dress so you go
over to five four club.com
and each month they send you a curated
box of 2 to 3 items that are hand-picked
to match the current season and your
style they've been helping men with
fashion for 15 years they ship to over a
hundred thousand men every single month
if you don't know how to build a
wardrobe they make it happen for you
right now you get a hundred and twenty
dollars worth of clothes for just $60 a
month you can pause or cancel your
membership at any time with no
commitments you also receive up to 50%
off items in their online shop they have
an online shop so it's not just you wait
for the box to come you can go and
proactively buy things access to
exclusive Members Only items free
shipping size exchanges right now go to
five four club.com you spell out five
and you spell out four so five for club
calm right now enter promo code Ben
they'll give you 50% off your first
month's package plus a free pair of
sunglasses so that means you get $120
with a close with just $30 for that
first month plus you get a free pair of
sunglasses that's fifty percent off your
first package at 5-4 club.com
FIV e fo you are club.com promo code Ben
five for club.com
promo code Ben I think that looking good
is an obligation in today's day and age
and five for club can help make it
happen for you if you don't know
anything about fashion even if you do
they'll make a wardrobe better 5 for
club comm promo code then to get that
special deal and let them know that we
sent you okay so let's start off with
this what is the alt right so the alt
right is marching in the streets and the
alt-right is is supposedly that there's
a lot of misperception people on the
left are calling everyone on the right
all right and saying everybody's a Nazi
that's absolute garbage ok the alt-right
is its own movement the alt-right is a
group of white supremacist who believe
essentially that Western civilization is
an outgrowth of white race and that
threats to white race are a threat to
Western civilization that's the basic
premise of the alright ok a lot of
people think they're all right now
because they like memes or because they
believe in in the god of cat Greg heck
is this like memory that you see on
4chan and reddit and a lot of people who
think that if they if they post a frog
that makes them a member of the
alt-right that's not what the alt right
is the alt rate has a basic root
philosophy what happened over time is
that the alt right was mainstream by a
group of people who decided to broaden
the definition to include people who
liked frog memes okay they decided to
broaden the definition and then they
used that broadened definition in order
to make the claim basically that they
were a big movement that had a lot of
support and then you saw people like
Donald Trump and Steve Bannon yes the
President of the United States yes his
chief strategist give legitimacy to the
alright and refused to condemn them
in the middle of the campaign which gave
them an added impetus and now you see
the marching openly in the streets
so with charlottesville trump's fault no
of course Charlottesville wasn't Trump's
fault any more than what happened in
Dallas a year ago it was Barack Obama's
fault where a guy who believes a lot of
the slogans of black lives matter went
out and shot a bunch of cops okay you're
only responsible for violence if you are
rhetorically calling for violence Trump
has never done that what he is
responsible for in some in some degree
is mainstreaming the alt-right and not
treating them as the as the as a cancer
to be excised from the conservative
movement that they really are okay and
again I'm talking about what the all
right actually means not what you think
it means not what people in the media
think it means the media has an interest
in pretending the alt rights a big
movement that includes people like me
two weeks ago they were labeling me
outright okay I was the number one
target of the alt-right in 2016 that's
fully insane and then there are bunch of
people in the all right who have a drive
to call people all right who aren't
because that way they get to claim that
they're a bigger movement than they are
but here's what the alt-right actually
is so some of these supposed thought
leaders of the alt-right are people like
Jared Taylor Jared Taylor is the creator
of American Renaissance which is a
racist website and here is Jared Taylor
talking about what exactly the Allred is
why don't we let the leaders of the
alt-right to find what the alt-right is
here is Jared Taylor a long-standing
member of the alt-right
this is how I see it we are a broad
dissident movement that includes many
different websites organizations and
viewpoints some members hold distinctive
positions on sexuals trade and free
markets forms of government and foreign
policy but they all agree on one thing
equality is a dangerous myth the
alt-right is united in rejecting the
current dogma that all races are equal
races are different they differ in
average levels of intelligence they do
not build identical societies and there
is no reason to think non-whites can
maintain Western civilization the
civilization that whites created okay so
that is that is Jared Taylor pointy I
mean that's a very good synopsis of what
the alt-right believes and he's not the
only one who says this Richard Spencer
and one of the guys who's at this rally
yesterday a sort of Nazi sympathizing
piece of garbage here is Richard Spencer
also summing up what the alt-right is
well I would describe it if I could sum
it up in one word I would say identity
it is an identity rien movement it's a
an identity politics for white people in
North America and really around the
world so that's what the alt-right is
just in one sentence or a bumper sticker
okay
okay and he's not the only one either
Vox Dei who's another member of the
alt-right again one of the alt-right
thought leaders all these guys are very
active online all these guys are very
active in promoting their their
perspective they have a lot of followers
on places like 4chan and reddit and they
latched onto Trump for a reason I'll
explain in a second here's Vox Dei
making the same exact description as
Jared Taylor and Richard Spencer people
tend to look at our Richard Spencer who
is the head of the National Policy
Institute and also some guys like Ramsey
Paul some people even look at Mencius
mold bug and Nick land but you know
they're really much they're really more
nail reactionaries than an alt right
proper and you know some folks have even
looked at me I think probably because my
look called me an alright figurehead a
few months ago okay so this okay so this
should be a fringe movement right a
bunch of people who believe that
equality before law is not a thing that
racial equality is not a thing and even
the concept of people being equal as
individuals is not a thing because we
are all characterized by our race so
this was a fringe movement the left has
made it more of a movement because the
left has embraced an identity politics
of its own the left has basically said
okay you are a white male you white
males you you exist because of white
privilege and therefore you must be
moved out of power right we have
identity politics and so a lot of white
people people like Vox Dei and Spencer
and Taylor they say in response okay
well you have your identity politics
we'll have our identity politics will
have white identity politics we will be
a group of people who stands up for
white pride because white people are
awesome right this has been the response
and that has come along with a lot of
anti SJW stuff so a lot of people who
are just anti SJW anti social justice
warrior but who aren't believers in
racial inequality and racial disparity
who aren't advocates of racism and
anti-semitism a lot of those people they
fell into the trap of thinking that they
are allies of people like Vox Dei and
Richard Spencer and Jared Taylor
there have been a couple of figures
who've been very prominent in helping to
mainstream the alright one of these
unfortunately is a guy who directed a
lot of his sort of altre followers that
may on Twitter and became very popular
mildly innopolis so Milo is very popular
he's very popular because a lot of the
stuff that he said on campus you know a
year ago about feminism a lot of it is
irreverence and some of it is funny and
all of it is is crazy and out of the box
and he says inflammatory things
deliberately and all of this okay but
Milo was very very instrumental in
mainstreaming the alt right and treating
the alt-right as an intellectual
movement that ought to be respected and
given its fair hearing
this was his schtick right his schtick
was he was gonna pander to the alright
he oh he later came out and said I
separate off from the alt-right they're
not me I have problems with the
alt-right but that didn't stop him from
going on national television and talking
up the alt-right and saying he just
wanted to give them a fair hearing here
he is on CNBC last your doing exactly
this no I mean I've never identified you
alright the press seems determined to
crown me the queen of it all I've done
is give them a fair hearing in the press
I think that white identity and white
nationalism is a little misleading I
think it's more accurate to say that the
alt-right cares about Western supremacy
rather than white supremacy it cares
about Western values it cares about
liberal capitalists Western democracy
democratic values freedom equality that
kind of thing and it sees in a various
threats to those from various fronts
okay so you see what he's doing here
okay what he's did Milo knows better
than this okay because he's been dealing
any circles for a long time he
apparently used to call himself my love
ogner okay Milo knows what he is doing
here and what he is doing here is he's
broadening the definition of all rights
very clever
he's broadening the definition vault
right on national television - now
encompass a larger group and this serves
two people ray or it serves two groups
it serves the alt-right itself which now
gets to claim a larger constituency and
it serves left we get which gets to lump
in everybody who believes in Western
civilization with people like Jared
Taylor Richard Spencer and Vox Dei
here's Milo writing on the alt-right
last year this was the seminal piece
that really brought the alt right to
public public knowledge there's a piece
called the establishment conservatives
guide to the alt-right it was written by
Milo along with a guy named Alan Bukhari
who who wrote a Breitbart com
there's about a month after I left
Breitbart and here is what Milo wrote
quote there are many things that
separate the alternative right from
old-school racist skinheads alternative
right is a term coined by Richard
Spencer that is alt-right alt-right
stands for alternative right there
any things that separate the alternative
right from old-school racist skinheads
to whom they are often idiotic ly
compared but one thing stands out above
all else
intelligence skinheads by and large are
low information low IQ thugs driven by
the thrill of violence in tribal hatred
the alternative right are a much smarter
group of people which perhaps suggest
why the left hates them so much right
left doesn't hate them cuz the racist
left hates them because they're
dangerous they're dangerously bright
this is Amal Milo okay Ismail already
the media empire of the modern-day
alternative right coalesced around
Richard Spencer during his editorship of
takis magazine in 2010
Spencer found an alternative right calm
which would become a center of all trite
thought for alongside other nodes of
Steve Saylor's blog vedera and American
Renaissance alternative right became a
gathering point for neglected mix of
renegades who objected to the
established political consensus in some
form or other you see what's happening
here do you see how evil what's
happening here is taking the philosophy
the evil philosophy of people like Jared
Taylor and Richard Spencer and Vox de
Milo wrote the foreword to Vox daze book
okay they're taking the political
philosophy the Milo knows well and then
broadening it out to suggest that it
applies to everyone who wants to defend
Western civilization I want to defend
Western civilization I've spent my
entire career defending Western
civilization I spent my entire career
defending the Declaration and the
Constitution my original break with Milo
online actually came over not over the
Michelle filled stuff for the Trump
stuff or any of that stuff they deleted
his accounts he can you you should be
able to look it up but one of the but it
came originally over Milo suggesting the
constitutional conservatism was dead and
ought to be replaced by the alternative
right okay that's where the break came
on Twitter so it's what he did here by
mainstreaming the alt right was create
the feeling that they were a burgeoning
movement wasn't just my love there are
other people doing it too Steve Bannon
who at the time was running Breitbart
which was making Milo its star
figurehead Steve Annan said we are the
meeting place for the alt-right he
celebrated that they were the meeting
place for the alt-right then he became
the head of Trump's campaign and now
he's the chief strategist at the White
House and meanwhile President Trump and
yes Trump bears some responsibility in
the growth of the alt-right president
Trump we will just go through the
timeline he continually during the
campaign refused to disassociate from
all trite figures or even racist figures
okay this is I hate to keep polenta I
hate to go back and play this stuff but
it's now relevant okay here's a
flashback this is from March 2016
month that Milo wrote this pace this is
this is Trump refusing to denounce the
KKK and David Duke well just do you
understand I don't know anything about
David Duke okay I don't know anything
about what you're even talking about
with white supremacy or white
supremacist so I don't know I mean I
don't know did he endorse me or what's
going on because you know I know nothing
about David Duke I know nothing about
white supremacists and so you're asking
me a question that I'm supposed to be
talking about people that I know nothing
about but I guess the question from the
f-m the anti-defamation league is even
if you don't know about their
endorsement there are these groups and
individuals endorsing you would you just
say unequivocally you condemn them and
you don't want their support well I have
to look at the group I mean I don't know
what group you're talking about you
wouldn't want me to condemn a group that
I know nothing about I have to look if
you would send me a list of the groups I
will do research on them and certainly I
would disavow if I thought there was
something wrong but but you may have
questions in there that are totally fine
and it would be very unfair so give me a
list of the groups and I'll let you know
okay and then chapter kept repeating Ku
Klux Klan and Trump wouldn't go there
okay that was not the only time Trump
did this Trump was asked on national
television by Wolf Blitzer on CNN about
denouncing anti-semitic attacks on a
journalist named Julia Jaffe I haven't
read the article but I heard it was a
very inaccurate article and I heard it
was a nasty article I'm married to a
woman who's a very fine woman she's a
very fine woman she doesn't need this
believe me she was very very successful
she did tremendously well as a top model
she made a lot of money and and she's a
nice person and I guess some of the
articles says that she would go in at
night and she would stay she wasn't a
party person she you know it's not her
thing but this was a very this a very
high-quality woman who loves people and
is a big heart she doesn't need to be
have bad things said about her and I
heard the article was nasty
now I haven't read it but I heard the
article was not what it should be they
shouldn't be doing that with wives I
mean they shouldn't be doing that
Melania is a top model they sent
pictures around to Utah and
it wasn't even like NSYNC you followed
these anti-semite I don't know about
that I don't know anything about these
hands of mine suppose it faster your as
a posting these angry you'll have to
talk to them their message to these fans
is I don't have a message to the fans a
woman wrote a a article that was
inaccurate
now I'm used to it I get such bad
articles there's another incident where
Trump did this and again Steve Madden at
the same time talking about how his
website is the meeting place for the all
right and so what happens that the
alt-right believes that because Trump is
the anti political correctness and
because he's anti SJW and because he
keeps refusing to denounce the alt-right
in any sort of vigorous terms in Trump
never has a problem denouncing his
enemies and vigorous terms they begin to
latch on to him when that's not entirely
Trump's fault but it's at least
partially Trump's fault and so that's
why in Charlottesville so the fact is
okay and these are unpopular things to
say I know I know a lot of the people
who listen to the show voted for Trump
I'm not blaming you for voting for Trump
I never blamed anyone for voting for
Trump to stop Hillary Clinton but to
pretend that Donald Trump didn't have to
do with looking the other way with a lot
of the stuff during the campaign would
be just factually untrue it would be
factually untrue and I think it's
important for us as constitutional
conservatives to call out bad things
when they happen to call out evil
ideologies when they crop up the
alt-right is an evil ideology this
ideology that says white nationalism
this ideology that says that race is
inseparably tied from ideology that's
what I hate about the left I hate the
identity politics of the left and I
don't believe in the identity politics
of the right it's evil it's nasty
you think I stand with the people who
are flying Nazi flags and Confederate
flags and David Duke marching around why
is this difficult this is the easiest
thing in the frickin world to denounce
just announce it what the hell is wrong
with people and this idea that we went
for
year without announcing it we're making
excuses for it or patting it on the head
because we thought it was an important
movement in important constituency you
know what it's not an important
constituency it's like five people
number one it's not a lot of people
number two even if it were a million
people even if it were five million
people even if there were thirty million
people you do not pander to the worst
people the planet has to offer you do
not pander to Americans who don't
understand what Americanism and and
promote an ideology that is contra
Americanism you do not do that for
political gain that is sick and it is
vile okay and there are a lot of people
who are doing it during the campaign and
it's continued now and should stop
immediately and even people on the right
now know this ok a lot of people on the
right now know that listen I feel the
same way about the left when it comes to
the left who won't announce an ephah
when it comes to the left that won't
denounce the Marxist intersectionality
philosophy that they've been
promulgating when the left won't
announce riots in Ferguson or Baltimore
when the left continues to pretend that
violence in places like in places like
Berkeley and Sacramento in Seattle and
Richmond in Charlottesville coming from
the left or they pretend all of that is
no problem at all the only problem is
that at the right all they're doing is
pushing people into the arms of the
alright you have two vile movements
pushing more and more people into each
others arms it's horrifying it's
horrifying and disgusting I'm gonna get
to Trump's response in just a second
before for that you're gonna have to go
over to Daley wire calm $4.99 a month
you can subscribe to daily wire it I
kind of get my show live you get Andrew
Clavin show live it's a video shows he
gets to see it you can see all the video
that we're showing which is imperative
when you're talking about topics like
this daily wire calm $9.99 $9.99 a month
michael Knowles's show is live today
that's starting and I think 12:30 today
and I'm sorry 1:30 today and kleavon's
show comes up right after this one at
like 10:30 so so stick around for that
when you get the subscription of daily
wire calm or even an annual subscription
and with the annual subscription for $99
zero you get this the most magnificent
tumbler that ever was or shall be
leftist here is hot or cold from the
daily wire and you got this tumbler less
so it is so you get that with the with
the annual deal or just go over to
iTunes or SoundCloud and subscribe make
sure it do both you know subscribe to
our site and go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud and hit subscribe and leave
us a review we always appreciate it we
continue to be by far the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so why is all of this relevant it's
relevant because you know we don't have
to go nuts every time a horrible thing
happens in the United States people are
killed by evil people in the United
States every day we do have to call it
out when we see that the President of
the United States once again refuses to
openly call out the alt-right okay I
know the president Truong I don't think
it's coming out of any sort of sympathy
for the alt-right I don't think the
Trump is an alt writer I don't think the
Trump is a racist I don't think he's an
anti-semite I do think that President
Trump has this unfortunate and kind of
gross Achilles heel where anybody who
supports him in any way anybody who's
been warm to him gets warm treatment
from Trump and anybody who's mean to him
gets nasty treatment from Trump right
the proof in point is we'll hear Trump
statement in just a second
but this morning the head of Merck and
the Merck CEO a guy named Kenneth Fraser
who's a black guy the only member of
president Trump's Commission is his
panel on American manufacturing or his
Council on American manufacturing he
resigned this morning because of Trump's
comments which he felt didn't go far
enough and Trump promptly won hunt
Witter and denounced him and suggested
that he was involved in in price fixing
essentially so Trump went directly after
him we've seen him go harsh after people
like Nico Brzezinski and Joe Scarborough
and Britt Hume and mid John McCain and
then Ted Cruz and had Cruz's father and
Ted Cruz's wife move seen him go hard
after a thousand people when it comes to
the outright then suddenly he seems to
swallow his whistle and it turns into
okay well I just condemn everybody
equally here is what Trump had to say
immediately after all of these events on
Saturday we condemn in the strongest
possible terms this egregious display of
hatred bigotry and violence on many
sides on many sides it's been going on
for a long time in our country not
Donald Trump not Barack Obama it's been
going on for a long long time it is no
place in America what is vital now is a
swift restoration of law and order and
the protection of innocent lives no
citizen should ever fear for their
safety and security in our society and
no child should ever be a for
to go outside and play or be with their
parents and have a good time okay and
then he continued use he who
specifically asked about white
supremacism and he just walked away from
the podium apparently here he is talking
about how hate and division have to stop
I just got off the phone with the
governor of Virginia Terry McAuliffe and
we agreed that the hate and the division
must stop and must stop right now we
have to come together as Americans with
love for our nation and true effective
really and I say this so strongly true
affection for each other okay so this is
nonsense okay well what he's saying here
is milquetoast nonsense and what the
reason it's milquetoast nonsense is not
because we shouldn't call for unity we
should but this would be a good time to
call out all of the bad people no Trump
spent an enormous amount of time over
the last five years saying that Barack
Obama refused to call out radical Islam
that was true and Trump has been very
strong and forthcoming and correct and
calling out the dangers of radical Islam
okay he should be just as forthcoming
and calling out both the alt-right for
what it is and Antipa for what it is
there's nothing wrong with him getting
up there and saying the alt-right
represents an evil racist movement and
it's an evil racist ideology it's
disgusting and and in use of violence is
unjustified in any civilized country and
you could say the same thing or
something similar with regard to the
antifa Marxist group that seems to
believe that everybody who they disagree
with ought to be protested not only
protested who cares not protest that's
fine but punched and you could have said
all those things it's not difficult none
of this is hard none of this is
difficult but Trump didn't do that so
you said all this and everybody went
wait that was it that's all you got and
we can hear the rest of his statement
though many incredible things happening
in our country so when I watch
Charlottesville to me it's very very sad
above all else we must remember this
truth no matter our color creed religion
or political party we are all Americans
first we love our
country we love our God we love our flag
okay so it's a bunch it's a bunch of
just stuff right I mean he just has a
bunch of stuff and if Obama had done the
same thing and he did do the same thing
I ripped him up and down at the time go
back listen my podcast after the Dallas
shootings I did the exact same thing at
the time in fact here was Barack Obama
doing something very very similar after
the Dallas shootings the FBI is already
in touch with the Dallas police and
anyone involved in these senseless
murders will be held fully accountable
justice will be done I will have more to
say about this as the facts become more
clear for now let me just say that even
as yesterday I spoke about our need to
be concerned as all Americans about
racial disparities in our criminal
justice system I also said yesterday
that our police have an extraordinarily
difficult job and the vast majority of
them do their job an outstanding fashion
I also indicated the degree to which we
need to be supportive of those officers
who do okay no point ever even come
close to condemning the ideology the
police are the bad guys at no point did
he come out and say that in fact at the
funeral for the Dallas slain he came out
and reiterated that police officers were
what was driving the entire conflict at
the time I said this is disgusting what
Obama's doing go back and listen to it
at the time I said this okay so nothing
new Under the Sun but it doesn't matter
if it's coming from left or from right
evil people evil ideologies should be
condemned full-throated Lee this is not
difficult it's not difficult okay so the
media of course have gone over have gone
insane over all of this like beyond even
what is necessary I think this is a
critical moment for the country
apparently President Trump is gonna
speak momentarily about charlotte's
they'll probably try to put a bandaid
some ointment on the boo-boo it's a
little bit late okay you should have
done this by Saturday I don't understand
why this happened okay the White House
came out later and they made some sort
of statement suggesting well he really
meant that he condemned the the all
right when he said his statement why
doesn't he just come out and say that
why didn't you just come
why with 48 hours to do a presser it's
ridiculous there's no reason for that
and his silence means something to the
bad guys okay here's the daily stormer
this is a national neo-nazi website
quote trump outright refused to disavow
people saying he cooked cooked means
people like me who don't like racism
anti-semitism
we are cox according to the alt-right
slang again not to bring milo up again
milo sent me a picture of a black baby
on the day of my son's birth because i
was a because I didn't sufficiently
support the alt-right agenda or
President Trump the idea behind the all
right the word is that people like
me are for race-mixing and therefore are
fine with my wife having sex with a
black man that's the idea so that's what
the language means as people saying he
cooked our chills and that's the
actual word they use he did the opposite
of cuck he refused to even mention
anything to do with us when reporters
were screaming at him about white
nationalism he just walked out of the
room okay that may be unfair to Trump
but that's what the white nationalists
are seeing that's what the white
supremacist are seeing which is why it
is important for good leaders powerful
leaders to come out and condemn evil
when they see it God's sake it's not
difficult it's not difficult because the
media of course says the Trump shares
responsibility for what happened in
Charlottesville that I disagree with
again I think Trump shares
responsibility for the growth of the
alright I think that Obama shared
black lives matter movement and for the
intersectional SJW movement but to
suggest that Trump shares responsibility
for the violence again Trump has not
espoused violence so that's just a left
wing talking point
here's Cokie Roberts making that point
though who shares responsibility and
this who shares responsibility it's not
only a man is not only in the movement
but anybody that points their fingers at
Mexicans and Muslims shares
responsibility way to share
responsibility the fact is is that
through that campaign he blew all kinds
of whistles that those of us who grew up
in the Jim Crow South like I did
recognized immediately it was just
calling out to these white supremacists
who then felt empowered by it and the
president now not calling them at you
know he should listen to nikki Haley his
now you in a master she's the person who
started bringing down
at monuments at the point she did it so
graciously in exactly the right tone
Ocasek aliens have mother and I know
she's talking about Confederate
monuments as though it's Confederate
monuments that are really driving all of
us gay the Confederate monuments about
have been around for a long time it's
not the Confederate monuments that are
driving all of this I think there's good
arguments made on both sides of the
Confederate monument issue but I don't
think that the argument is that Trump
created the violence in Charlottesville
because that's not right by the same
token you have people from the right
defending Trump's response Tom Bossard
is one of trumps aides and he gives an
absurd explanation for trumps comments
the president not only condemned the
violence and stood up at a time in a
moment when calm was necessary and did
and didn't dignify the names of these
groups and people but rather addressed
the fundamental issue and so Jake what
you need to focus on is the rest of his
statement the president didn't just call
for human beings to respect one another
which is his pragmatist core fundamental
bare-minimum but he called for ideally
Americans to love one another for all
God's children to love one another okay
that idea that he didn't to dignify the
alt-right by naming them didn't want to
dignify them it's absurd Trump did an
entire speech last week on ms-13 okay
his whole point over and over has been
that you must name the bad guys
otherwise you can't fight them he's only
said that 1,000 times over the course of
his career a charming Massa there
there's a desperate attempt by someone
that in the White House to try and cover
for this and that's fine I mean I think
that Trump needs to correct this as soon
as possible I assume he's doing that
right now as we speak
here's HR McMaster trying to trying to
pretend that Trump actually did a
sufficient job well the president's been
very clear we cannot tolerate this kind
of bigotry this kind of hatred and what
he did is he called on all Americans to
take a firm stand against it this is a
great opportunity for us to ask
ourselves what are we what is it okay
against bigotry against hatred this is
the same sort of nonsense that Trump
kept saying was unacceptable throughout
his campaign you can't just say that
radical Islam is just hatred or bigotry
you have to say what it is what is the
problem even Anthony Skinner Moochie the
mooch was on TV yesterday even and that
wouldn't last Newt Gingrich Newt
Gingrich said Trump should've been
stronger on this and then the mood came
out and said the Trump should've been
stronger on this one you've lost the
mooch and Gingrich that's a pretty good
indicator you didn't do a good job with
this I think you needed to be much
harsher as related to the white
supremacist in the nature of
I applaud general McMaster for calling
it out for what it is it's actually
terrorism and whether its domestic or
international terrorism
with the moral authority the presidency
you have to call that suppression okay
so I think that in the end what we're
watching in the United States and this
is the scary part what we're watching
right now this is why strong powerful
moral leadership is necessary if we
don't if we're not careful we're gonna
end up with a red versus brown shirt
situation in the United States that's
what you're watching on the streets in
Charlottesville it's what you're seeing
in Seattle it's what you're watching not
in Seattle so much they're just saying
Red's not even brown shirts but it's
what you've been seeing in in places
including Berkeley or Sacramento you're
seeing an alt right movement that is
racist in nature fighting a red movement
that is violent in nature and they're
going right at each other and all that
happens is that people play off one
another for power okay to understand the
rise of the Nazis and we're not in that
moment I hope I hope to God but to
understand the rise of the Nazis you
have to understand most Germans did not
believe in the Nazi Party most Germans
just hated the Reds for taking over
towns and threatening the country and so
they thought that the Nazis would stop
them is some tape of Joseph Goebbels
making exactly the same sorts of points
that Richard Spencer and Jared tailored
and box day like to make here is here's
Joseph Goebbels
talking about how he is going to he and
the Nazis are gonna end the Red Terror
was called the Red Terror in 1931 1932
hundreds of people's killed in street
battles between the SA which was the
Hitler stormtroopers and the Reds which
were the Communists here is Joseph
Goebbels evil one of the most evil men
in history not talking about this says
the end of the Red Terror is closer than
you think
communists
expect to get the worst drumming you've
ever had
[Applause]
then you see the cheering throngs that
is the 1933 election is the 1933
election they're even they're even
flying the same we can stop it there
that that of course is is tape from from
the Nazi era they're even flying the
same flag she's on Nazi flags in
charlottesville you saw communist flags
in charlottesville it is so easy to fall
into the trap of thinking that the enemy
of my enemy is my friend
the enemy of my enemy is not necessarily
my friend they may also be an enemy of
Western civilization it is possible but
in a fight between Nazis and communists
everyone is bad it is possible that both
ideologies are violent it's possible
that violence on all sides is vile and
if we don't have leadership that can say
all this then I don't know what to tell
you not just not just in vague
terminology not just everybody has
responsibilities not just violence and
bigotry on all sides no call out the
ideology because if you don't do that
people are gonna label conservatives
alright people are gonna label liberals
SJW left okay and we're all going to
just polarize into these two opposite
camps that are the worst of the worst
okay so very quickly time for some
things I like and then some things I
hate so things I like if you don't know
anything about the history of the Third
Reich and how it rose and why this is
all very very dangerous and you need to
read William Chivers the rise and fall
of the Third Reich history of Nazi
Germany it's I would say the second best
book on the history of Nazi Germany that
I've read the best is this the
three-part series by Richard Evans but
this is a very deep detailed book by a
guy who was present in Nazi Germany
during the rise of the Nazi Party again
the book is the rise and fall of the
Third Reich it is a slog it is a very
long read it's like 900 pages but when
you finish you'll be more scared for
civilization when you finish than you
are now as well you should be because
civilization is a fragile thing and what
we are watching is the greatest
civilization in history and in tension
simmering under the service that
threatened to tear it apart okay time
for a quick thing I hate so
the thing that I hate today is Bill
Maher on Friday night he dislikes
President Trump so much that he is
hoping the stock market crashes that
Trump falls apart here is Maher making
this case I thought he would crash the
stock market and I don't think he will
I'm hoping actually because that's one
thing that would maybe lose him a lot of
support and and the Republican Party but
I thought and predicted and I was wrong
that the stock market hates volatility
and uncertainty and who is more volatile
than Donald Trump but I guess I
underestimated their greed because they
still want their tax cut ok so again one
of the big problems here is that the
left is so focused on taking down
President Trump they don't actually want
what's good for the country and I would
say that there are people on the right
who sometimes are so focused on
protecting President Trump that they
don't want what's good for the country
either how about we all want what's good
for the country and we all want policies
from our politicians and moral stances
from our politicians that are good for
the country and if people don't uphold
those moral stances on either side we
call them out this is not difficult
politics is is valuable politics is
necessary politics reflects deeper
values but if we can't share values of
decency if we can't share values of
freedom and and liberty to say what we
want if we can't share values where we
hope for prosperity for the country then
we're just doing it wrong we're just
doing it wrong we become nihilists and
god forbid we should become nihilists
and destroy the greatest civilization
the world's ever known go be back
tomorrow I'm hopeful the President Trump
will correct his errors of the weekend I
hope the president from forcefully
condemns the alt-right and begins his
separation from them as well he needs to
do we'll talk about it either way i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
you